宜しくお願いします
いろんなことを
たくさんしゃべらなくては
いけないのですから
何も前置きなしに
いきなり
私のテーマについて
しゃべりたいと思っています
「心と病気の関係」という
テーマでございますが
鈴木さんが「大変易しい 簡単な話」だと
思っているようですけど
もし話になると
大変
とんでもない難しい話になる
可能性はあるのです
それを忘れて
いろいろ考えていましたけど
なかなか解決方法は
見つからなかったのです
一応 私は思ったのは
何か病気の人々を集めて
何か病院みたいに
何とか治療みたいなものを話す
ということではないのです
それよりは
病気を治して
健康な体を作る
技ですか
術ですか
それを何か
専門的に プロに
話してあげたかったのです
ということは 私の話を聞いて
自分で実践してみて
いくらか健康な体を作ることが
できれば良い
という立場で話をしたい
と思っていたのです
とにかく
よく聞いてください
何とかなるのではないかと思います
特に日本とアメリカとか そういう
二つの国でも
また他の国々もその影響で
宗教というのは 何か
ヒーリング(Healing)
ヒーリングというのは
「癒す」ですか？
そんな仕事をやっていることだと
思っているのです
僕らはとても それは
いやらしく感じるのです
なんとか病は 宗教から
いろいろ病気を治してくれたのだと
癌を治してくれたのだと
という ものすごく
仏教の者は それはとても
「いやらしい宗教だな」と
思うようなものなのです
何とかして人の病気を治した
ということは
ですから それをまず
覚えておいて下さい
それで 何とか何とかして
何とかお祈りをして
何とかして
その人の病気を治しましたと
そういうのは それほど
高次元的なものではないのです
なぜならば
そんなに病気を治した
形跡はどこにもないのです
宗教であろうが
どんな何か神秘的な..
力であろうが
もしそういう神秘的な
とても巨大な力があって
人の病気を治したならば
世の中には もう
病気は 全部消えているはずなのです
ですから
宗教家が 一生懸命病気を治すし
でも それを信じている人々は
一生懸命病気になったりするし
それはキリがないのです
ですから その方法は
我々は断っているのです
お釈迦様に禁じられているのです
人の病気を治すとか
そういう
行動はやめなさいと
お釈迦様の言葉を借りて言うならば
それは...
「邪（よこしま）な生き方」なのです
ですから 僕もかなり
心配しながら 話さなくては
いけないのです
もっとレベル高く
高度に
高度なレベルで
このこころ
身体
病気
そういうものはどういうものかと
理解していただければ
病気を治してもらうより
もっと良いことになるかもしれません
では
話に入りますけど
分からないかもしれませんが
これは聞いて覚えておいて下さい
我々の身体というものは
こころが作るのです
こころというのは
魂（たましい）ではないのです
何かエネルギーなのです
精神的なエネルギーなのです
この精神的なエネルギーというものが
この肉体的な身体を作っているのです
それで皆様方は
良く聞いていらっしゃるのです
占いをしているのです
手相占い 人相占いとか
それから 書いたものを見て
占ったりするとか
そういうのは
完全に嘘ではないのだけど
結構当たるのです
手相などはインチキな人ではなくて
お金ではなくて
趣味でやっている人から
読んでもらったら
結構 当たるのです
お金を取って読む人は
全部嘘を言ってますけど
そこで
人相占いであろうが
他の占いであろうが
人の顔を見て
歩き方を見て
喋り方を見て
声も聞いて
色々占ってもらうと
「あ 結構当たるんではないか」と
そういう経験 皆様にあると思います
でも 当たらないのは
それを商売にしている時なのです
それで食べていると当たらないのです
本人の商売だから
何とかして
人の機嫌を取ろうとしているのです
ですから ものすごい嘘を言うのです
趣味で 冗談で 遊びでやっている人は
人が傷つこうがなかろうが
それに構わず 言いたいことを
言ってしまいますから
本当のことを言ってしまうのです
そこで 私が言うのは
なぜ手相を見て 人の性格が
分かりますか？
なぜ人相を見て 人の運命やら
これから何か悪いことに出会うならば
そんなことがなぜ分かりますか？と
それが分かるのは
その身体は
私のこころが作っているのだから
こころの状態
性格
私の生き方を
身体にちゃんと映しているのです
ですから そういうのは
いくらか当たるのです
だからといって 仏教では
そんなものは
信じるなと
手相やら 人相やら
それから星占いとか
そんなものは 全部もう
ゴミ箱にポイ捨てしなさいと
そんなものは何の意味もないのだと
僕も結構いろんな人に
僕の手を読んでもらったことが
あるのです
遊びで...
お金を払っていないのです
そこで 色々言うのですけど
結局言っていることは
私は知っているのです
「あなたは こういう
こういう（人）ではないか」
「こういう（人）ではないか」と
「まあ そうです」と
私が「知っています そんなことは」と
自分の知っていることを
人に聞かせてもらっても
別に
どこが 何が面白いかと
分からないのです
それで 私はチャレンジするのは
「では できれば  私が知らないこと
を言ってください」と
それは言えないのです
手相を見ても 人相を見たとしても
ですから この身体は
こころが作るものだから
我々の顔を見たら
だいたい分かるのです
どんな人間かと
皆様もそうでしょうに
ちょっとかなり仕事で
ストレスが溜まってしまうと
胃やら 腸やら 全部もう
だめになってしまうし
もう髪の毛はかなり早く
白くなってしまってしまうし
かなり年取ってしまってしまうし
ですから この
例えば 20歳なのに
30代ぐらいの顔を持っていると
当然 分かります
この人はかなりこころで
悩んでいるのだと
いろんな問題で
悩んでいる
ということが良くわかるのです
例えば 70歳になった
おばあちゃんであろうが
とてもかわいくて
若々しくいるならば
ものすごい精神的に
ストレスが何もなく
元気で健康的でいる
ということなのです
ですから もし
病気になりたくなければ
健康なこころを作ることなのです
それで お釈迦様は
健康なこころを作る方法を
教えているのです
しっかりした
どんなものにも壊れない
どんなものに対しても不満が出てこない
しっかりした
こころを作る方法を教えてくれるのです
それを実践すれば
もう病気などは
消えていくだろうと
なぜならば
こころが 身体を作りますから
そのこころが
しっかりしているこころであるならば
身体も 適当に
治っていくのです
ですから 私が申し上げたいのは
自分の病気なんかがあるならば
そんなものは 忘れてしまって下さい
そんなことはどうでも良いのです
足が痛い
お腹が痛い
心臓は良くない
腎臓が良くないとか
慢性的な肝炎とか何とかとか
そんなものはどうでも良いのです 別に
いったいこの身体は何ですか？と
身体というのは ヤドカリのように
一時的に使っているだけなのです
一時的に使うために
こころが作ったものなのです
ですから 分かりやすく言えば もし
例えば
血液関係の 何か障害があるのだと
それはその本人が
勝手に病気になっているだけなのです
こちらに文句を言っても
何の意味もないのです
お医者さんに文句を言っても
環境に文句を言っても
食べ物に文句を言っても
自分が勝手に病気になっている
だけなのです
ですから
それで病気になると
みんな身体に文句を言うのです
何とかが悪い とか
或いは 両親に文句を言ったりするし
仕事に文句を言ったりするし
それは誰のせいでもないのです
例えば かなり仕事が忙しくて
大変きつい仕事で
ストレスがたまって
身体を壊しましたと
いったら 会社にも仕事にも
文句を言うよりは
私は 文句を本人に言いたいのです
あなたは才能もないのに
良くも仕事しているのですね
その仕事を辞めなさいと
そんなにストレスが溜まるのだったら
あなたにその仕事はできないのだと
良く仕事ができるのだったら
ものすごい簡単に
遊ぶみたいな感じで
仕事をするのです
髪の毛が白髪になったり
もう禿げてしまうし
男はだいたい禿げてしまいますから
それはしょうがないのですけど
それはホルモンのせいで
それより早く禿げてしまうし
年を取ってしまうし
おじいちゃんになってしまうし
それはもう厳しい仕事を
しているのだからと言って
それどころか
そのストレスを家まで持っていくのです
奥さんに文句を言うのです
私は もう仕事をしてくるのだから
もう疲れているのですとか
子供の面倒なんか見る暇が
ないのです とか
それで僕から見れば
才能ない人だなと
なぜならば
男であるならば仕事をするのは
当たり前であって
家に帰ったら 奥さんと
ちょっと仲良くして
子供たちとちょっと遊んで
子供たちが何かいろいろ
悪いことでもしているならば
それは正しく指導して
教えたりするのは
やっぱり男の仕事なのです
男の仕事の半分やらない
仕事だけをやるというのは
もう「半分男」なのです
いくら会社で偉そうな
仕事をしていても
それでは才能ある人には
ならないのです
才能ある人は 全部まとめて
きちんとやるのです
と同時に 何もストレスは
溜まっていないのです
とても健康的なのです
奥さんにしても 同じことなのです
子育てに追われて
身体を壊しましたと
言うと
私はあまりはっきりと
（相手が）女性だから
言わないのだけど
もう全然才能がない
子育てには全く才能がない
ということなのです
母になる資格はないのだと
母になったら
子育てで病気になったとか
そんなものをもう
認めるわけにはいきません
例えば だいたい赤ちゃんの時は
（親は）夜は寝ることができない
赤ちゃんというのは
良く夜に起きますから
それもお母さんが悪いのです
昼間に寝かしておくのです
うるさいのだからと言って
それで 子供は昼間に寝て
夜に起きるのです
ざまあみろと...
だから それはそれで
そこで お母さんたちが
みんなに文句を言ってしまうのです
旦那さんに当たってしまうのです
ストレスがたまっているのだと
本当はたまるはずがないのです
我々のこころに十分この資格というか
才能というか
そんなものはないからなのです
いつでも皆様方
どこかで かなり心配事があるのです
例えば 美しい女性がいても
どこかで「もうちょっと...」
あるいは「自分が本当に美しいか」と
どこかで不満があるのです
それで どこかに不満があるのだから
そういう不満を解消するために
いろんなことをする
いろんな もうエアロビクスもするし
お化粧もするし
いろいろおしゃれもするし
いろんなことをする
それをすればするほど
その不満が大きくなってしまうのです
「もっと美しくなりたい」と
頑張れば 頑張るほど
皆様方が忘れていることは
自分が自分のこころに
「私はそれほど綺麗ではないのだ」と
無意識のこころに暗示をかけているのです
お化粧をすればするほど
それで早く醜くなってしまうのです
それはもったいないのです
そういうこころの働きを
皆様は持っているのです
男性もそうなのです
どこかで自信がないのです
例えば 子供の時に勉強する
勉強しても
「自分には勉強できる」
という自信がないのです
その自信がないから
更に勉強する
塾に行く
塾に行くと頭が良くなるかというと
良くならないのです
ただ 丸暗記するだけ
同じ内容は
１０回 １００回 ２００回 ３００回も
先生たちから聞いて 聞いて 聞いて
もう嫌になるほど聞いて
頭に叩き込んでしまうのです
それは知識ではなくて
「無知」なのです
知識というのは
自分で物事を理解することなのです
そこでずっと不満な人が塾に行くと
塾に行く度に
私には勉強する才能がないのだと
だから塾に行くのだと
だから 「遊ぶ時間でも
勉強しているのだ」という
自己暗示をかけているのです
だから みんな病気になるのは
当たり前ではなくて
病気にならなかったら
不思議でしょうがないのです
だから 僕が言いたいのは
逆なのです
日本の皆様方は 不思議と
良く元気ですねと
本当は みんな病気で
倒れているはずなのにと
それぐらい
もう子供の時から 我々は
ストレスのプロなのです
日本では ストレスを解消する方法
ではなくて
どうすれば良くストレスが溜まるかと
そればっかりみんな研究して
良くやっているのです
それで病気になっているのは
当たり前なのです
いくら仕事をしたとしても
経済状態が不安定になるのは
当たり前なのです
例えば 本屋さんには
僕は良く行くのは
本屋さんなのですが
本屋さんにある
本の数々を見ると
もう嫌になるのです
どれほど この人間が
落ち着きがないのですかと
ちょっとしたことに
もう専門雑誌が出ているのです
例えば コンピュータゲームでも
遊び方に また
専門雑誌が出ているのです
それでコンピュータの種類によって
また雑誌がいっぱい出ていて
このゲームによって 雑誌が出ていて
それから 料理にしたら
雑誌は もう百冊以上あるのです
それで何でもかんでも
専門雑誌いっぱい
それは「知識的に豊か」ということで
我々は 自分たちを
ごまかしているのだけど
僕から見れば
「落ち着いていない連中だな」と
ゲームだったら
自分勝手に発見しながら
遊べば良いのに
何で雑誌を見て
ゲームの遊び方を勉強する？
そうすると ゲームにならないのだから
料理でも 自分で研究しながら
自分で間違えながらも
色々やって 新しいものを
発見すれば良いのだから
旦那さんも子供さんもいるのだから
実験台として...
お母さんは怖いのだから
作るものは 全部
文句を言わずに食べるし
ですから そうやって
実験すれば良いのに
もう一生懸命 雑誌を開けて
一生懸命 勉強して作るのです
それで
かなりストレスがたまってしまうのです
なぜならば もう
「成功」と
「そうではない」という
判断があるのだから
本の通りに出来上がったら
「大成功」と
そうではなかったら
「失敗しました」と
そういう風に）
何でこころを痛めるのですか？
例えば 自分勝手な料理を作って
作ったところで
それで成功でもないし
失敗でもないのだから
こういう風に料理しましたから
こういう風に出来上がったと
食べられるものならば
食べて下さいと
それで勉強して
これは食べられないのは
こういう訳ですと
次回は それを直せば良いのだから
ものすごくリラックスして
生きていられるのに
我々はもう
子育てから 死ぬまで
いかにストレスが溜まるかと
ただそれだけを考えて
生きているのです
それで当然ながら病気になると
また文句を言ってくるのです
そこで悪い
怪しい商売をしている人々がいるのです
どこでもお金が入る方法があったら
すぐそこに...人が商売するのだから
そこで病気を治す商売は
かなり盛んなのです
気功法で病気を治すとか
あるいは運動療法で病気を治すとか
いろいろあります
自然食ですか？
そういう方法で病気を治してくれるとか
瞑想法から病気を治してあげるとか
神通力で病気を治してあげるとか
霊の力で病気を治してあげるとか
僕は一人で考えているのだけど
そんなに病気を治してあげるのだから
ならば 一人も病人が
いないはずですけど
何でいるのですかと
結局 向こうも商売をしている
だけなのです
こっちは もう
儲かるものです
日本では 絶対ストレスは
止まりません
赤ちゃんにも
ストレスを作ってしまう
それから 死ぬまで
ストレスが溜まっているし
それで病気になるのは当たり前なのです
ですから この病気を治す
ヒーリングの方々は
限りなく儲かってしまうのです
僕から言えば 限りなく
儲かる権利があるのは
食料品を作る人々だけなのです
次に 服とか作る人々なのです
なぜかというと
毎日 食べなくてはいけない
死ぬまで食べなくてはいけない
それには終わりがないのです
ですから 農業関係の人々は
儲かっても それは罪がないのです
毎日食べているのだから
服とかそういうものを作る人々も
儲かってもしょうがないのです
結構儲かっているのは
そちらの方ですけど
可哀想に
農業の人々は それほど
儲かっていないのです
それはとても良くないのだけど
それでおかしいのです
金持ちになるべき
農業の方々は
金持ちにならない
金持ちにならなくても良い
こういう いろんな
デザイン関係の人々は
かなり金持ちなのです
それはそれで
皆様のことだから
その人々で三番目に
お医者さんなのです
なぜならば
いつでも病気になるわけ
ではないのだけど
たまに人間は病気になる
その時はお医者さんの
お世話になる
死ぬ時までも
病気になる可能性がある
ですから
農業の関係と
服装の関係と
病院の関係
その３人が儲かっても良いのです
ヒーリングとか
そういうことをしている人々は
良く知っているのです
いくら自分が力を入れたとしても
いくら自分が神通力やら
超能力やら
神の力やら
こういう媒体を通して
治したとしても
明日また病気になりますと
明日また私が儲かりますと
そういうことを知っているのです
ですから 私が言いたいのは
そうではなくて
いっぺんに自分のこころの問題を
治してくださいと
私は儲かりませんから
どうしたとしても
ですから
いっぺんに皆様の
こころを治す方法を
教えてあげたいのです
こころを治してしまえば
身体は綺麗に
治っていくのです
そこでちょっと
テーマがおかしくなりましたけれど
何で こころが病気かというと
色々なことで病気なのです
一番わかりやすいのは
ストレスの病気なのです
母はストレスが溜まっているし
父はストレスが溜まっているし
それで赤ちゃんにも
ストレスが
かかるようにしてあげる
ですから
できれば自分たちが
今 赤ちゃんがいる方々
いらっしゃらないようなのですけれど
我々は 赤ちゃんの時も やっぱり
落ち着くことを
教えてあげなくてはいけないのです
それでいろんな道具を使って
赤ちゃんが泣く時は
いろんな道具を使ったり
おもちゃを使ったり
いろんな音を使ったりして
落ち着かせてしまうのです
あれも
できるだけ やめた方が良いのです
赤ちゃんの機嫌が良い時には
おもちゃをあげたり
いろいろ面白いものを見せたりして
遊んで良いのですが
かえって我々は 赤ちゃんが
泣いたり 神経質になったりするのを
やめさせるために
道具を使ってしまうのです
そこから間違っているのです
例えば 赤ちゃんが
お腹いっぱいミルクを飲んで
ニコニコ笑って 遊んでいると
その時はいろんな道具を見せたり
いろんなことをしてあげたりして
遊んだ方が良いのです
遊んでいる時だから
それから 赤ちゃんが
何となくちょっと
ストレスが溜まったりして
泣いたりすると
そんな道具とか 全部
置いといて
やっぱり こころが落ち着くことを
してあげた方が良いのです
小さな赤ちゃんだったら
お母さんが抱っこすることが一番...
良いのですけど
それ胸に抱っこをしてあげたり とか
そうすると どんどん落ち着く
あまり話しかけない方が
良いのです
本人も落ち着いていないのだから
別に話しかけたとしても
更にストレスが溜まって
しまいますから
それでお母さんが
子供の機嫌が良い時
いっぱい喋ったりして
機嫌が悪い時はあまり喋らないで
もう無言で
ただスキンシップだけで
落ち着かせてあげると
そういう風にしてあげると
小さい時から
ストレスが溜まることは
どんどんなくなるのです
残念ながら 教育戦争で
幼稚園に行かせると
そこでまたストレスが溜まるし
小学校でまた溜まってしまうし
中学校でと ずっと
その一方なのです
そこで仕事に入ったら 更に
結婚すれば また
子供が出来たら また
とか そういう風に死ぬまで
仕事が終わったら もう
やることがないのだから
またストレスが溜まったりするし
それは癖なのです
仕事があるから
かなりストレス溜まっている と
「では 一休みあげます」と言ったら
「やることないな 退屈だな」と思って
またストレスなのです
皆様方は じっとして
ボケーっとしていることが
できないのです
ちょっとひと休みすることが
もし30分あれば どうしますか？
もし私が30分あげたら？
とてもイライラするでしょう
かなりイライラするのです
ということは
かなりのストレスなのです
30分あったら
本も読まないで
寝ることもしないで
ただ じーっと待っている
ことができれば
そのストレスは
全部消えてしまうのです
何にもしないで
考えることもいけない
でも 寝ることもいけない
それはちょっと難しいかもしれません
そういう風に簡単なのです
こころを癒すことは
黙って じーっとしていれば
もうこころは治るのです
なぜそれが出来ないのか？とは
それは まあ
私には出来ますから
しょうがないのだけれど
皆様に何で出来ないのかと
皆様から聞かないと
では
ストレスが溜まらないように
どうすれば良いのですか
そこは 問題なのです
それは 自分のことを
余計な判断をしているでしょう？
それを置いておいて下さい
我々はあまりロクな人間ではないのだと
そんな大したものではないのだと
大した美人でもないし
大した知識人でもないのです
そんな我々に大した仕事が
できるわけでもないのです
だから 適当に ほどほどに
まあ 頑張っているのだと
その考え方が
一番良いのです
それは社会に入ったら 何か
ものすごい危険な考え方のように
聞こえますけど
それは危険ではないのです
大したことをしようとして
世界を破壊して
みんな自己破壊の道に
行っているのだから
女性の方々は
ものすごく自分を
美しく見せるために
綺麗に見せるために
何でもかんでも完璧にしようと思って
かなり苦しんでいるのです
「まあ そこまでしなくても良いのだ」と
ホッとすれば
あの恐ろしい苦しみが 全部
じわじわと消えてしまうのです
男性の場合も
「ものすごいしっかりしなくては」とか
「しっかり仕事をしなくては」とか
「完璧に仕事をしなくては」とか
「完璧に勉強しなくては」とか
そんな余計な くだらない考え方
止めてほしいのです
なぜくだらない考え方だと
申し上げるかというと
誰一人も完璧に仕事をしたことはないのです
皆 ほどほどにやっているのに
なぜこころの中だけ
かなり威張って
嘘をついているのですか 自分に？
自分はしっかりしているのだと
それは 嘘なのです
ですから 正直になって
「まあ 物事はほどほどで良いのだ」と
「完璧には 出来ません」と
例えば こちらで私は
ヴィパッサナー瞑想指導はしていますけど
その時でも
なかなか結果が出てこないのです
実践する人々は
なぜかというと 頭の中で
「まあ しっかりやります」
と思っているのです
私は「それは嘘だ」と
知っているのですけど
言ったら怒られますから
言わないし
「嘘を言うな」と
だから 自分に出来るだけのことを
精一杯頑張ってもらえば
私は ものすごい早く成長するように
指導できるのに
それはなし
正直ではないのです
だから 僕にもしゃべりたくても
しゃべりようもなくなってしまうのです
だから どんな社会にしても
そんなものなのです 人間は
だから もうややこしくなりますから
覚えておいて下さい
もう「完璧に物事をしよう」と思うことは
不自然です
非現実的です
「不完全で良いのだ」と
「でも いい加減ではありません」と
「それは 私の精一杯だ」と
世界が評価するのは
我々の「精一杯の仕事」であって
「完全な仕事」ではないのです
お母さんには
「完全な子育て」はできません
決して
完全な子供を育てようと思ったら 結局
殺人者で終わるのです
ですから それはありえないのです
お母さんから 社会は
必要としているのは
「まあ 精一杯頑張って下さい」と
それで子供はどうなろうが みんな
「あのお母さんは
一生懸命頑張りました」と
それを褒めるのです
そこで子供も
「お母さんもお母さんなりに
良く頑張りました」と
「では 私もいい加減なことを
してはいけないのだ」と
と良くなるのです
完璧主義
潔癖主義とか
そんな病気を まず
簡単だから 捨てて下さい
こころの中から
ですから
覚えやすいように言うならば
完璧になるのではなくて
まあ
「精一杯する」と
自分に まあ出来る範囲で
とことん頑張るのだと
ですから 誰かが
「それはちょっと
間違っているのではないか？」
と言ったとしても
別に気にする必要はないのです
例えば 男性の場合 仕事は
「自分が精一杯しました」と
そこで上司が
「あなた これ そこら辺...
そこら辺 ちょっとダメではないか」と
そうしたら そこで
お腹が痛くなるでしょう？
痛くなる必要はないのです 別に
なぜかと言うと
自分が精一杯したのだから
「ああ すみませんでした」
と言えば それで終わります
「ああ そうですか」と
それだけなのです
そこで上司が頭の良い上司だったら
「その人は精一杯
頑張っているのだから...
それで十分だ」と
「もしその人が更に上達する
可能性があるならば...
更に上達するようにしましょう」と
もしそれはギリギリだったら
まあ
この残りの仕事を
他の人に頼むしかないのです
ですから その
レベルの高い「あきらめ」ですか
高度な「あきらめ」みたいな
ものなのです
「人間は不完全である」と
それでストレスが
全部消えてしまったら
結構 病気というのは
消えてしまうのです
それで 次のポイント
次のポイントはこれです
この
人生というのは
どう頑張っても
結構苦しいものです
皆様方 一生懸命
戦争が終わった時から
一生懸命頑張って
幸福な社会を作ろうと頑張ったのです
それで 経済的に
世界のどんな国も
追い越してしまったのです
それで
幸福になったのですか？
物はあるのだけど
物があることは幸福ですか？
幸福になるというか
我々はやっぱり
かなり人生というのは
大変なのです
戦争が終わった時は
当時の方々は食べ物はなくて
着る物がなくて
とても苦労したのです
その時は その痛みの強さによって
「ああ 十分食べ物さえあれば...
十分お金さえあれば...
我々は大丈夫だ」と
その時「勘違い」しただけであって
それで今は十分全部あるのです
十分ではなくて もっとあるのです
それでも 我々のこころは
また悩んでいるのです
未だに
家族の中で問題あるのです
未だに夫婦は喧嘩するでしょう？
未だに裁判では一生懸命
いろいろ裁判で戦っているし
なぜ幸福になったのならば
そういう問題があるのですか？
「世界一知識レベルが高い」
と言っているのです 日本では
でも
みんな 必死で狂ったような感じで
勉強しているのです
そんなに知識レベルが高ければ
ごく普通に勉強すれば良いのに
なぜこんなに狂っているのですか
教育に？
そんなにも頭が悪いのですか？と
だから 必死で狂ったような
勉強をするのは
頭が悪い人なのです
頭が良い人は勉強しない
ただ 一日中ふざけているのです
何で ふざけていることが
できないのですか？
例えば 学校に行った子供たちなんか
もし子供たちがふざけていると
先生はストレスが溜まってしまって
イライラするのです
ひどいのは それは先生には
「才能なし」
簡単に言うと それなのです
僕が教えていた時は
一生懸命 真面目に勉強する子は
あんまり可愛くはなかったのです
だから ふざけたり 何とかして
私を ごまかそうとしたりとか
だまそうとしている子は
やっぱりかわいいのです
だから こっちも
「このやろう」
「何かだまそうとしているのではないか」
と思って こっちもやる気が出てきて
もう教えるのです
それは 全く
みんながそうという訳ではなくて
私のちょっとした経験なのですけど
一生懸命 私の話を聞いて
メモを書いたり
ノートを書いたりした学生たちが
大体
それほど高い点数を
もらわなかったのです
よくよく見ると 私の言うこと
ただ単にそれを丸暗記して
そのまま書いているだけなのです
そこで私が気持ち悪くなるのです
自分が言ったことを
また繰り返し自分で
聞きたくないのだから 別に
生徒たちに言ったことは
私にとって別に面白くないでしょう？
私にとって面白いのは
もっとレベルの高い教育だから
だから この彼らの答案を読む時は
ものすごく
「ああいやだな いやだな」と
居眠りしながら
ほとんど読まない
ちょっと見て
「あぁそう まぁこんなものです」と
そこで いい加減な答を書いている
学生たちがいるのです
かなり気になってしまうのです
「何だこれ？
いい加減なことを
書いているのですか」と
そこで読んでみると
まぁ
「あぁ やっぱりこいつは
勉強していないのだ」と
分かるのです
分かるのだけど
何かどこかで
可愛いのです
勉強していないのだけど
「何とかしよう」と
頑張っているのです
別に 本人が自分の力で
そこで私は
「ああ 良し...
世界に必要なものはこういうものだ」と
私たちの言うことを
良く聞く人ではなくて
自分で何とかしようと頑張る人だと
ですから もうポイントを入れるために
「何かないのですか？」
と探すのです
一生懸命
探して 何もケチをしないで
堂々とポイントをあげるのです
ですから そういう
ただの例だけなのですけど
頭が良い人の場合
別にそれほど必死で勉強
教育を受ける必要はないのです
「知識レベルでは高い」
というのだけど
みんな かなり強烈で
教育競争をしているのです
それは何ということはなく
ただ単に皆様のストレスだけなのです
「一生懸命勉強しなかったら 大変だ」と
事実を見て下さい
勉強しても しなくても
同じことなのです
みんな
結局 どこかで会社で
サラリーマンになって
それで人生が終わるのだから
可哀想なのです
子供なのに遊ばないで
かなり勉強して
たまに子供たちは
その疑問を大人に聞くのです
「勉強して どうなるのですか？」と
そうすると 良い子なのに
その子供を連れて行って
カウンセラーの所に行くのです
ある日 ある子供が自殺して
文章が書いてあったのです
結構古い話なのですけど
その子は 文章が書いてあって
「学校は何のためにあるのですか？」と
「教育というのは どんなものか？」と
いろいろ疑問がいっぱい書いてあって
とても綺麗な文章でしたけれど
そこで その人のことを
あまり先生もあまり
気に入っていないみたいだし
他の生徒たちもそれほど
気に入っていないみたい
「いい加減なことを言っている奴だ」と
「わがままだ」と
僕は あの文章を読んだところで
「ああ もったいない子供だな」と
「素晴らしい子供だな」
と思ったのです
もし 私がああいう子供に出会ったら
僕は宝物のように育てるのです
なぜかというと ものすごい
いい加減だから
自分の言いたい放題 言うのだから
自分の意見を述べるのだから
ロボットではないのだから
本物の人間なのです
そこで 本物の人間が
たまに出来上がったら
どうしますか？というと
我々はみんなその人を
殺してしまうのです
この自殺する子供たちが
自分で自殺するのではないのです
大人がそうさせているのです
学校の先生たちも 親も みんな
だから こころはもともと
とても自由なのです
それを押さえようとしているのだから
そうなっているのです
だから 恐ろしいものなのです
ですから 我々は
言いたかったのは 少々
ポイントが外れましたけれど
また戻ります
教育は最高なレベルに行ったとしても
私たちの苦しみはそのままなのです
必死で勉強しなくてはいけない
という苦しみは
そのままなのです
経済的な
最高な 最頂点に上っても
必死で仕事をしなくてはいけないと
成長率は 更に更に
高くしなくてはいけない
という苦しみがそのまんまなのです
「昔の日本人は...
ちょっとしたことで喧嘩したのです」と
「米の問題とかちょっとしたことで
お金がなかったのだから」
「昔良く喧嘩したのは
貧しかったのだからと
偉そうに我々は
嘘を言うのだけれど
「では 今 なぜ喧嘩して
いるのですか？」と
ということは 豊かであろうが
我々お互いのこころの葛藤は
そのままなのです
何一つもこころの問題は
解決していないのです
昔も 今も これからも
ということは
人生というのは 結局
頑張ったとしても
水の泡なのです
みんな一生懸命頑張るのだけど
結局 最後に全部パーなのです
何にも結果がないのです
空しいのです
では 子育てに必死になっている
お母さんたちが
知っているでしょうに
一生懸命「命でもあげます」と思って
子供を育てるのだけど
まあ 14 15 16（歳）になったら
どうなるのですか
子供は？
お母さんをぶん投げて
出て行ってしまうのだから
それで自分が寂しくて
一人でじーっと待っているだけなのです
全然帰ってこない
結局 最後はそんなものなのです
我々は歳をとって病気になってくると
子供は助けにならないし
旦那も助けにならないし
奥さんも助けにならないし
もう薬も効かないし
それで空しいのです
ですから この人生というのは
究極的に すごく空しいものである
苦しいものであると
我々の努力は  結局
無駄な方向の努力である
ということをまず確認して下さい
ポイントは ここから来るのです
それは暗い確認なのです
暗い確認だけど 本当なのです
その本当のことを確認した上で
（何でも良いのです適当に）
それをしっかり確認して
忘れないように
できれば 自分の部屋やら
台所やら あっちこっち
トイレでも あっちこっちに
書いておいてください
その もう暗い文章を
人生は
空しい 苦しい
それは 皆様のストレスと
病気を治す方法として
こうおっしゃっているのだから
試しにやってみて下さい
人生は 結局どう頑張っても
空しいですと
どんなことをしたとしても
苦しいですと
最後は 全部パーだと
書いてみて下さい
一週間以内で 皆様方
何か結果が得られるはずなのです
それからのポイントなのです
今 皆様方 私に答えてくれたのです
（人生は
空しい　苦しい
最後は死です）
では 皆様方 一応答えを
知っているのです
では 人生は 結局
最後はそうだから
どうすれば良いのですか？
今 皆様は何をなさったのですか？
私の話を聞いて？
何のこともなく
ニコニコ笑ったでしょう？
そこなのです別に
だから 結局もう
アホなことだから
やっているのは所詮
ですから 何で苦しんで
ひどい顔をして
泣きながら 悩みながら
いるのですか？
何の意味もないのです
必死で鬼の顔をして
勉強したとしても 結局もう
馬鹿になるのだから 最後に
どれほど勉強しても
歳をとってしまったら
もう ただのアホですから
あの勉強は 全部無駄なのです
そこで 我々男たちが
若い時は 一生懸命元気で
健康的で 頑張って
しまうでしょう？
歳をとると 奥さんに手を
つないでもらって歩くのです
恥ずかしくてしょうがない
でしょう 男なのに
奥さんが小さい時は
体が弱いのだけど
もう80歳になっても
いくらか元気なのです
僕は老夫婦を見るのです
いつでも 老夫婦の間では
旦那さんが ものすごい身体が
病弱 弱いのです
奥さんの方が いつでも支えて
奥さんも 病気で
おばあちゃんなのに
歳をとっている自分の旦那さんを
支えているのです
おかしいのではないですか
世の中というのは？
男は すごい力が強くつくために
頑張ったのに
何だ あの結果は？
ですから 我々は必死でスポーツするわ
勉強するわ
仕事をするわ
お化粧するわ
いろんなことをして
結局 何もないのだから
私が言うのは
楽にしなさいと
そんなにストレスが溜まる
必要はないのだと
勉強は 気楽にして下さいと
楽しく お遊びとして
遊びは 最後に何もないでしょう？
人生というのは
ゲームみたいなものだから
ゲームというのは
やる時は楽しいのだけど
終わったら ゲームオーバーで終わり
ゲームセンター いろいろあります
百円 二百円入れて
もう何とかチャーチャー
カチャカチャとやって
ゲームをやってます
それで百円が切れてしまったら
「ゲームオーバー」と
それで悔しいのだけど
帰らなくてはいけないのです
人生も そんなものなのです
女性の若い時の美しさの戦いも
一つのゲームなのです
それを３５、４０代になるまで
そのゲームをやって
中年になってきたら
もうゲーム終わりと
止めてくださいと
我々は そうではなくて
また更に続く場合もありますけど
それは何にもないのです
男の力強さのゲームも
４０代になってくると
もうほとんど
ゲームオーバーなのです
ですから それに
なぜそんなに必死で
歯を噛んで 鬼の顔をして
やっていますか？
とても楽にしましょう
スポーツと同じです 全部
人生は
例えば 野球とか見に
いらっしゃるでしょう？
その時は行って いろいろもう
叫んだり泣いたり
いろいろ応援したりして
終わったら帰るでしょう
それだけのことだから
ですから 仕事であろうが
子育てであろうが
教育であろうが
家の 奥さんの 家の仕事であろうが
とてもリラックスして
ニコニコのんびり
「のんびり」という言葉は
少しおかしいのだけど
ニコニコとやらなくては
いけないのです
それができるのは
何も 最後に意味がない場合
だけなのです
「これは大変だ これは大事だ」と思うと
みんな真剣になってしまうのです
でも 「大変だ 大事だ」ということは
何一つも 世の中ではないのです
全部 終わるのです
例えば 三菱とか
名前を挙げるのは
大変失礼なのですけれど
大きな会社があります
日本では
巨大な会社とか
そういう風な
巨大な会社を作ったとしても
もう兆単位でお金を持っていたとしても
死ぬ時は 何も持って行かない
ただ（の）一円もなし（の）
人で死んでしまうでしょう？
だから バカバカしいではないですか
結局？
必死で 何のために金儲けしたのですか？
あれは 何の役に立ったのですか？
何でもないのです
ですから
皆様方 できれば まあ
住友でも良いのだけど
三菱でも良いのだけど
トヨタでも良いのだけど
それぐらい大きな会社を
作りたければ
どうぞ作って下さい
でも それに命だけはかけるなと
そんなものは ゲームであると
ちょっとした
退屈だからする
ゲームなのです
それは真実ですから
それを理解すれば
パッと人生は明るくなるのです
ですから お釈迦様は
「人生は苦である」と
「空しい（も）のである」
とおっしゃったのは
それを理解する度に
人間は 幸福が見つかるのです
皆様方
天国に行って 或いは
極楽（浄）土に行って
幸福になると思っているでしょう？
だから そこはおかしいのです
今 人生 一生苦しんで
一生馬鹿をして
死ぬ時も 馬鹿を見るだけであって
極楽には行きません
今もダメな人は
どうやって 次に良くなるのですか？
ですから 僕は本気で言っています
今の人生は かなり真剣に
真面目に
みんなに迷惑をかけて
ストレスばっかり溜まっている人が
死ぬ瞬間になっても
ものすごいストレスが
溜まってしまって
死にますから
どうも残念ながら
明るい所に行けるということは
ちょっと難しいのです
今から明るさが見つからないと
つかまえていないと
今もリラックスして のんびり
「ああ いつ死んでも良いのだ」と
「人生はゲームだから
死ぬまでのゲームだ」と
仏教で
瞑想して 完璧に悟りを開いた人が（を）
阿羅漢（あらかん）と言うのです
仏陀（ブッダ）と言うのです
その阿羅漢になった人は
何も欲望はないのだと
欲望がないのだから
何のために生きているのですか？と
それを質問して聞かれたことが
あるのです
そこで答えたのは
「別に目的があって
生きている訳ではなくて
目的は何もないのだ」と
「ただ 死ぬまで待っているのだ」と
それは 理想的な生き方なのです
ちょっと死ぬまで待っている
それだけのことなのです
ですから
何だこの戦争みたいな
生きる戦いか？と
みんな戦争みたいに
生きるために戦っているのです
戦っても 勝てないでしょうに
生きるためにいくら戦っても
死ぬのだから
だから 可哀想に
なぜ苦しむのですか？
この短い人生で
瞬間も苦しむ必要はないのです
いつでも明るく 明るく
いることは
できるのです
できるのは
ただバカみたく明るくなったら
ただのバカですから
知識的に明るく
ならなくてはいけない
どうやって知識的に
明るくなるかというと
この人生は
結局 空しいのだから
結局 どう頑張っても パーだから
では 明るくしましょうと
必死に仕事をしたとしても
５５歳 ６０歳になると
我々はお払い箱でしょう？
ですから
この会社にいる短い間では
元気で 気持ち良く 仲良く
お互いに足を引っ張らないで
お互いに嫉妬しないで
頑張ればいいのに
それどころか 会社の中で
ものすごい
弱肉強食の戦争なのです
だから 自分で勝手に
苦しんでいるのです
それで病気になるのです
ですから 病気を治す 身体を治す
２番目のポイントは
全てのものは 苦であることを理解して
物事にそれほど真剣にとらわれないで
ものすごく明るく 明るく
その瞬間 その瞬間
充実して生きることです
これを良く覚えておいて下さい
ちょっと文章は長いのだけど
人生は苦しい（もの）で
あることを理解して
物事に執着しないで
その時 その時
明るく
充実して
その瞬間 その瞬間
生きることです と
人生は苦であることを理解して
物ごとに執着せずに
明るく 充実して 瞬間 瞬間を生きること
ですから
分かりやすく
かなり引いて
短くしています
今の瞬間
今の瞬間 私たちに
明るく
ニコニコと
元気でいることができれば
それで満足して下さい
例えば 病気であろうが良いのです
「今の瞬間 どうですか？」と
「今は別に いくらか我慢できる」と
「それで十分ではないのですか」と
それは
ものすごい高度な
深い真理なのです
僕はものすごく
皆様におっしゃっていることは
今も実践して喋っているのだから
何かいい加減に
喋っているような感じなのですけれど
本当はとても深い
宇宙の法則の こころの法則の
真理に基づいて
今もしゃべっているのです
そういうことを言ってしまったら
皆様方 驚くほど
難しい世界かもしれません
でも だからといって 私も
「そんなことはどうでも良い」
ということで
「今さえ明るく 皆様 理解すれば良い」
ということで 簡単にしゃべるのです
でも 今 私が言っていることは
一つも
冗談ではありません
真理であることだけ
覚えておいて下さい
そこで
ちょっと伝統的な仏教に戻りますけど
我々に この仏教の人々に
お釈迦様が
大変親切に
良く毎日毎朝観察するものを
教えているのです
人間なら余計なことを考えるのだから
お釈迦様は
「そんな余計なことを考えるな」と
「考えたら あなた方は
信者さんのご飯を食べて...
飛んでもないのだ」と
ですから
「こういう風に考えてください」と
「その方が明るい考え方だ」と
おっしゃっているのです
明るい考え方だと
おっしゃっているのは
どういうものかというと
いつでも 自分の身体は
とても汚いのだと
臭いのだと
醜いのだと
ものすごい不浄だと
徹底的に実感して 観察しなさいと
皆様とちょっと違うのです
我々 皆様というのは
失礼なのですけれど
世の中の人間が考えていること
とは違うのです
お釈迦様が言うことは
お釈迦様は
そういう考え方は明るいのだ
と思っているのです
その身体は この古い
便所に喩えているのです
古いというのは
使って 使って
もうそれ以上使えない
いわゆる不浄なもので
もう満杯になっているのです
それで 古くて満杯になっている
便所というのは
どこから見ても
汚いのです
そういう風に
自分の身体を見て下さい と
観察してください
身体からいつも出るモノは
全部 汚いのだと
それは事実なのです
身体から出るものは何ですか?
出るものは？
金 銀 宝石？
お金？
身体から何が出るのですか？
身体には 金 銀 宝石 お金やら
いろんなものが必要ですけど
身体が作るものは何ですか？
かなり高価な料理を
身体に食べさせますけど
身体はそれは工場に入れてしまって
何を出すのですか？
だから 不浄を作る工場なのです
汗が出るは 唾液や鼻水が出るは
どこから見たとしても
大便 小便
何から何まで汚いのです
ものすごい綺麗な服なんか
１回 ２回着たら
もう汚くなってしまうし
すごい とても汚い（ものの）
塊（かたまり）なのです
ですから それを観察して下さいと
それが一つ
もう一つ
私は 今は元気ですけど
いつ病気になって倒れるか分からない
いつ死ぬか分からない
いつ私の持っているものは
なくなるか 分からないと
そういう風に観察して下さい
私の好きな人々
きょうだいやら親戚やら
子供たちやら
お友達やら 色々好きな人は
一杯いるのだけれど
そういう好きな人々から
いつ離れるか分からないのだと
私は 全部捨てて行かなくては
いけないのだと
この世の中で
どんな偉い先生になっていても
全部捨てて 一人静かに
寂しく出て行かなくては
いけないのだと
そういう風なことを
観察して下さいと
それは色々な瞑想方法なのです
あるいは 身体の構造を
観察して下さいと
「私 私」と威張って
高慢で思っていますけど
別々に見ると
ものすごい汚いものだと
例えば 皮膚
人間の皮膚なんかむいてみることを
想像してください
例えば 鹿とか虎とかの
動物の皮膚などを
むいてみたら
ものすごい高価な
輸入禁止にしているのです
虎の皮とか
それぐらい高価なものなのです
人間の皮なんかはどうですか
皮をむいてみたら
想像することができないほど
気持ち悪いのです
象の歯なんかは
輸入はどこにも禁止
持っていることも
禁じられているのです
国際法で
でも 象さんが死んでも
あの歯一本は
何十万円もかかります
（かつて）商売が出来ていた時でも
とても高価なものなのです
私たちの歯は？
歯が抜けてしまったら 誰か
売りに出してみてください
売れるかどうか
例えば すごいお金を払って
ものすごくみんな入れ歯などを
使っていますけど
「これにはもう３０万円かかった」とか
「４５万円になった」とか
偉そうに言うのだけど
その入れ歯は売れますか
１円でも？
そういう風に 身体の部分に分けて
歯を観察する
皮膚を観察する
髪の毛を観察する
身体の毛を観察する
内臓を観察する
腎臓とか 心臓 肺 胃 腸
腸の中のものとか
観察してみてくださいと
そうすると ものすごく
気持ち悪くなるのです
それは狙いなのです
例えば
死んでも 例えば
サンマとか カツオとか
いろいろ 何でしたか
大きな魚は...
マグロとか
死んだあの死体は
マグロとか 何十万円ぐらい
かかるのです
大きなものだったら
小さなサンマ一匹でも
１００円以上かかってしまうのです
人間 死んでしまったら
何円ですか？
だから 牛の心臓であろうが
肝臓であろうが
結構 高いのです
人間の腎臓なんか
心臓なんか
焼肉にして食べる人が
いるのですか？
バーベキューにでもして
だから
「バカなことを思わないで
本当のことを見なさい」と
「それこそ道徳であって真理だ」
というのは
お釈迦様の言葉なのです
「だから いい加減にして下さい」
「自分の身体を見て下さい」と
それを とても暗い考え方
のように思うのは
全くアホな人々なのです
ですから お釈迦様は
うるさいのだから
世の中の人間には
すごい形容詞で褒めているのです
それはどういう形容詞かというと
「完璧に狂っているのだ」と
世の中の人間が
「みんなバカです アホです」と
「全くの無知だ」と
だから お釈迦様の
おっしゃっていることを
実践するならば お釈迦様は
「もう何とか頑張っている奴だな」と
それで理解するならば
知識人だ 賢人だと言うのです
賢者だと
そうでなければ 我々に
お釈迦様が言っているのは もう
「狂っているのだ」と
「狂人だ」と
「もう あっち行け」と
そういう お釈迦様から見れば
ものすごく迷惑なのです
ですから お釈迦様の言葉は
厳しいかもしれません
厳しいのだけど
それこそ真理なのです
あなたの身体を見て下さいと
観察して下さい と
そういう風ないろいろな
瞑想方法があるのです
何でこういう風に見させるのですか？
まずそれは「本当のこと」です
私たちは 必ず死にます
この身体は 徹底的に不浄な
汚いものなのです
剥製というのですか？
動物なんかが死んでしまったら
保存します 何とかして
剥製にして 置物として
見ているのです
人間が死んで （剥製が）あったら
我々は逃げるのです 怖くて
人間が死んだら
剥製にして置かないのです
怖くなるのです
ですから すぐ
燃やしてしまうのです
燃やして どこかへ お墓に納めて
すぐ手を清めて 身体も清めるのです
塩をかけて
お寺は大変だから
みんなのお位牌とか
いろいろなものを
置いておかなくては
いけないのだから
みんな何か自分が逃げたような感じで
ですから
人間に怖いのだったら
オバケが出るのだったら
我々も同じものでしょう？
ですから みんな
同じオバケなのです
お互いに見て
逃げなくてはいけない存在なのです
とにかく そういう風なことを観察すると
この我々の余計な執着
生きていかなくてはいけない
仕事しなくてはいけない
金を儲けなくてはいけない
子供の面倒を見なくてはいけない
子供のために
いっぱい財産を作って
おかなくてはいけないとか
そんな ふざけた考え方は
全部消えてしまうのです
消えて 人間というのは もう
徹底した精神的なリラックスを
感じるのです
ものすごいリラックスを感じるのです
それはもう言葉で言い表せないほど
ものすごい良いリラックスなのです
「私はいつでも
死にます」と
「いつでも
死ぬ可能性があります」と
それを実感として思うと
ものすごい簡単なのです 人生は
例えば 私はこのカバンを持って行く
それをどこかに忘れてきてしまったと
全然「あぁ大変だ どうしよう
どうしよう」とか
汗が出たりとか そういうのはないのです
死を観察する場合は
「まあ そんなもの
持ち物だからなくなるものだ」と
ですから
これを実践してみるならば
皆様方 生まれて初めて
「生きることはこんなにも幸福ですか」と
分かるのです
例えば 我々のこの集まりは
今日限りだと分かると
とても楽なのです
お互いに全然喧嘩する必要はないし
「あの人 気持ち悪い」とか
何とか思う必要もないし
ほんのちょっとの間の
付き合いだから
できるだけ 頑張って
仲良くしようとしている
のではないかと
会社に入ったら
なぜお互いに競争して
苦しみますかというと
「永遠に自分が会社にいる」と
思っているからでしょう？
ほんの少々の間の付き合いだと
分かれば 何ということもないのです
かなり楽なのです
ですから
「幸福を味わってください」というのは
お釈迦様の
言葉なのです
願いと言ったら失礼なのですけれど
我々にそうおっしゃっているのです
「幸福を味わうために
真理を知って下さい」と
「全く無知な人には
幸福を味わうことはできないのだ」と
例えば 科学的な知識があるのだからこそ
我々はこういう現代科学世界を
作っているのです
電気というのは 神様だと
雨というのは 神様だと
思っていたら
電気を作ることはできますか？
昔々の人々は 雷が落ちたら
「神様どうか許してください」と
拝んだのです
雷は神様の怒りだと思ったのだから
でも 後の人々は
「あれ？ちょっと待って下さい」と
雷とはどんなものかと考えたら
それは静電気の塊であることやら
電気やら それを発見して
電気を自由に使えるところまで
知識は発達しましたと
そこで 我々の今
電気文化が出てきているのです
それで 私たちは楽をしているのです
今 楽をしているのは
誰のお陰でしょうかと言うと
知識のおかげなのです
「物事を知っているから」なのです
ですから
幸福は
物事を知っている者が
得られるものであって
バカな人は得られるもの
ではありません
ですから これから
悪口を言いますけど
あまり知識を得ないで
簡単に楽に
「神様 お願いします」とか
「仏様 助けてください」とか
そう願う人々は
とても暗いのです
幸福は味わえないのです
法則的には
それよりは まあ 人生は...
無常だと
まあ そんなものだと
不自由なものだと
そんなに真剣にとる必要はないのだと
明るく 明るく
とっていると
こころはリラックスするのです
リラックスするこころは それで
どんどん治っていくのです
こころが治ると
必ず体が治ってしまうのです
それは もう約束できます
では リラックスとか
それに基づく
ありとあらゆる病気のこと
それで終わりにして
まあ
またいろいろ病気がありますから
生まれつき この
遺伝的な病気になる場合もあります
その場合はどうしますか？と
遺伝に踏み込まれている場合は
もうこれは冗談ではないのです
なかなか そんな
治るものではないのです
遺伝的な病気だったら
でも 覚えておいてください
その遺伝的な細胞を作ったのは
私たちのこころなのです
私たちは わざわざ
そういう欠陥があるような
組み立てを作ったのです
我々のこころが
それはちょっと理解できませんが
もう本当は そういうことなのです
もし 自分たちが
遺伝的なことで
悩まされているならば
この生まれる瞬間で
自分のこころは そう決めたのです
ですから 誰にも文句を言う
必要はないのです
それに良く付き合うことしか
方法はないのです
その病気に
良く付き合う
病気と付き合うということは
この病気に対して怒りを持たないで
またリラックスすることなのです
例えば「足が弱い」と
足が弱いのだったら（といって）
別にどうということもないのです
それを気持ち良く 自分の
何といいますか
売り物ではなくて
いろいろ商品に
名前を付けているのです
ブランドネーム？何と言いますか
何々 ブランドですか？
あります
そんな感じで
自分の紋章みたいなものなのです
だから 例えば ある人が
「足が弱い」と言うならば
「私はもう生まれつき
足が弱いのです」と
それで明るく受け止めれば
足が弱いのだけは ちょっと
不自由はあるかもしれませんけれど
他の何の不自由もなし
何の不自由もなし
たまに 目が不自由な人とかいます
それで自分が
目が不自由であることは認めて
しっかりしている人々は
全然不自由は感じないのです
障害は感じない
堂々と元気で生きているのです
それは我々も驚かせられますから
その人々には
目が見えないのだけど
やること やることは
目が見える人々にもできないのだと
ですから そういう遺伝的な病気には
全く気にする必要はないのです
生まれつき目が見えなくて
不自由で生まれたのだと
耳が聞こえなくて生まれたのだと
そんなものは問題ではありません
それはもう覚悟して受け止めれば
すぐ そこに
明るいドアがあるのです
たまに 身体障害で悩んでいる人々は
口で筆を持って絵を描くのを
私はそういう絵を見たことが
あるのだから
それで素晴らしい絵を描くのだから
それでみんなが褒めたりするし
存在として認められているし
そのモノは売れるし
それで問題ないのです
ですから 障害を持って生まれることと
遺伝的にこの病気を持って
生まれることだけは
別に不幸ではありません
それは
自分が行ったことであって
自分のこころがそう決めたのだから
それは別に誰にも文句を言わないで
明るくその状態を認める
それだけ
それから 次の病気の原因というのは
微生物やら ヴィールスやら
そういうことなのです
その場合は お医者さんが
抗生物質とかいろいろ飲ませますけど
我々はもともと
他の生命に対して
「嫌だ」「敵だ」と思うこころは
忘れてください
ヴィールスから
大きなクジラ ゾウさんまで
生命は
敵ではありません
みんな同じ環境の中に
一緒に生活している
生命なのです
そこで「敵を作るな」と
敵を作ったら 叩かれますと
もし それは嘘だと思うならば
今日 家に戻ってから
隣の家に行って
文句を言ってみて下さい
別に理由はいりません ただ
ドアベルを鳴らして
「どなたですか？」と言われたら
「あなたね」とか 何とかかんとか
もう言いたい放題
文句を言ってみてください
どうなるのかと結果は？
どうなるのでしょうか そうすると？
あるいは 隣の奥さんに
「あんた 本当にだらしのない女ですね」とか
何か一言言ってみてください
分かるでしょう？
敵を作ったら どうなるのですかと
それを実践しなくても実行しなくても
我々は敵を作ると
恐ろしい結果が待っているのです
ですから お釈迦様の言葉から借りて言うと
微生物から
巨大な生命まで
生命であって
一人も敵ではありません
この人間だけ
他の生命は敵だと思って
戦っているのです
だから 人間だけ
この生命体の中にある
癌なのです
だから この身体の中に
細胞の中に がん細胞があるでしょう？
すごい好き勝手に
わがまま 高慢で
いい加減な細胞が
自分のわがままで成長するのだから
我々も癌なのです
人間そのものも
生命の構造の中で
だから やられるのは当たり前でしょう？
身体の中で 癌になったら
どうしますか？
放射線を当てたり 抗がん剤を入れたり
切ったり 燃やしたり
ひどい目にあうのではないですか？
だから 我々は自然から
ものすごく
やられているのです
攻撃されているのです
だから ヴィールスから攻撃される
エイズヴィールスから攻撃される
いろんなものから攻撃されます
それは 簡単に治ります
少しこころを変えれば
すべての生命は この生命体系の中で
みんなお互いに助け合って
生きている生命であるのだと
他の生命がいなければ
私には生きていられませんと
ですから 他の生命も
幸福で無事で生きていて欲しいと
なぜならば それによって
私も 幸福で 無事で
健康的で生きていられますからと
もし 牛やら
鶏やら
豚やら
会議でも作って
人間どもは私たちをいつでも
食べているのだから
これから人間に対して
強烈な怒りを作ろうと思ったら
あれを食べたら 死んでしまいます
毒になってしまって
だから 牛なんか 鶏なんか
人間は どれほど殺して食べたとしても
ものすごい優しいこころを持っているのです
だから 我々は食べても
それほど 身体は悪くはならない
魚もそうなのです
僕は 魚とか
そういう鶏とか
そういう動物に対して
本当に残念で 残念で
とても残念に思います
残念というのは
別な意味なのですけれど
あれほど人間に
いじめられているのに
やっぱり優しいのです
魚なんか もう
ちょっと付き合ったら
猫みたいに遊びに来るのです
皆様も そういう魚を飼ったり
遊んだりしているのではないですか？
本当は遊ぶどころではないのです
人間が良く魚を食べているのだから
※ボード上
１　身体は不浄です
２　私は一人で死んでいく いつ全てと離れてしまうか 分からないものだ
３　全ての生命（動物 植物 ビールス等）に至る
まで  自分の味方で敵ではない
他の生命も幸福で生きていて欲しいと願う
それでも魚はそんなことはあまり気にしない
※ボード上
１　身体は不浄です
２　私は一人で死んでいく いつ全てと離れてしまうか 分からないものだ
３　全ての生命（動物 植物 ビールス等）に至る
まで  自分の味方で敵ではない
他の生命も幸福で生きていて欲しいと願う
素晴らしいです 我々よりは
※ボード上
１　身体は不浄です
２　私は一人で死んでいく いつ全てと離れてしまうか 分からないものだ
３　全ての生命（動物 植物 ビールス等）に至る
まで  自分の味方で敵ではない
他の生命も幸福で生きていて欲しいと願う
ですから 私たちが 他の生命に助けられて
生かされているのです
この身体の中で 微生物だらけなのです
例えば 細胞一個を顕微鏡で見ると
どれくらい生命がいるのですか
細胞一個の中に？
いろんな別々な生命が入っているのです
ミトコンドリアとか いろんなもの
だから これらが一生懸命
頑張っているのだから
私たちが健康なのです
もし このミトコンドリアか何かは
核の中に入ってしまって
DNAなんか食べてしまったら
どうなるのでしょうか？
それで 我々は終わり
そうはしません
ですから 人間が悪いのです
バクテリアに反対するわ
戦争を仕掛けるわ
チャレンジをするわ
ヴィールスにチャレンジをするわ
だから
一生懸命 病気になる
それは この
競争ではなくて
「共存」
インドであろうが
自分の国（※スリランカ）であろうが
そういう南の国々というのは
とても汚いのです
食べ物なんか 店で売っていて
ハエやら ホコリやら
車の排気ガスやら
全然
何とももう健康的ではないのです
でも あれを食べて
人間が死ぬわけではないのです
また かえって
みんな それは平気なのです
私もちょっと
日本にいるのだから
「ちょっと なぜこんなに汚いのですか？」
と思いますけど
向こうの人に聞いたら
全然僕の話が分からない
僕もたまに聞くのです
「何であんた方は
そんなに汚いのですか？」と
ちょっとしたことで とてもきれいに
ごはんや食べ物が売れるのではないかと
「えー！？」と
全然分からない
彼らから見ればもう
蠅ぐらい止まったとしても
「何ですか？」という感じなのです
それで 車なんか道路でチャーっと行って
泥がチャーっと食べ物に
かかったとしても
それをちょっと手で拭いたら
それで十分ではないかと
それを食べて 別に人が死ぬのならば
もう みんなとっくに
死んでいるはずなのですけれど
あれは 確かにばい菌とかあるのです
科学的に言えば
でも ああいうのは
ばい菌もその人を見たら
私たちのすみかだから
ということで もう敵ではないのです
例えば 身体に病気を作る
ばい菌であろうが
その人々は 食べると
そういうばい菌 細菌が
身体に入るでしょう？
入ってみたら 別に何ということはない
自分たちがもう毎日住んでいる
もう住み慣れている「すみか」なのです
それで居心地が良いのだから
ただ住んでいるのです
それ病気にならない
エイズ・ヴィールスなんかは
ある人の身体に入ったら
何と言いますか？
抗体というのですか？
とにかくそのヴィールスは
なくなるのです
必ずみんなが病気になる
訳ではないのです
今は まあ 治療方法がないのは
エイズ・ヴィールスみたいな
ものですけれど
それは人のこころによります
人の他のシステムが
かなり仲良くしている
それで法則を犯す
エイズ・ヴィールスは
この法則を犯しているのです
このDNAの法則が
DNAの法則というのは
決まっているパターンで
行動することなのです
エイズ・ヴィールスだけが
その法則を犯しているのです
いつでも自分のDNA構造を
変えてしまうのです
そこで薬は効かない
身体にも抗体を作ることはできない
抗体を作ることはできないのです
いつでもプログラムが
変わってしまうのだから
それでも抗体が出来上がる
場合があるのです
出来上がって
ヴィールスをやっつけるケースがあるのです
その場合は その人々の身体の中は
ものすごく調和しているのです
それで 身体の中の生命は みんな
「なるほど 法律を犯している
奴がいるのだ」と
そうだとしたらやっぱりきちんと
罰せられなくてはいけないのだ と
ということで消えてしまうのです
それで私たちは法律を犯しているのです
生命の法律 法則を
生命の法則というのは
「お互いに助け合って生きて下さい」と
「一人では生きていられません」と
ですから 皆様方 このヴィールスやら
こういう原因からなる病気に対して
持っている怒り
「敵」感を
綺麗に消してください
きれいにこころから消すと
みんな生命だ
みんなお互いに助け合っているのだ
私の身体は一つの生命ではないのだ
数えきれない程の生命の塊だと
理解すれば
それで健康
問題はなし
毒を飲んでも当たりません
それははっきりと言えます
とてもしっかり精神的に明るい人が
知らないうちに毒を飲んだとしても
全然
当たりません
ちょっとした
悪くなっている 時間が経っている
食べ物を食べても当たりません
きれいに身体が処理するのです
身体は 頑張ってくれるのです
ですから
「敵を作るな」
ということなのです
最後にですが
そういう風に いろいろな方法で
病気を治しても
過去のせいで
いわゆるカルマのせいで
病気になる場合があるのです
皆様 一応仏教のことをご存知ですから
このカルマ 業ということは
分かっていらっしゃると思います
カルマ（業）
カルマ（業）ＫＡＲＭＡ
そのカルマというと
何か皆様方 暗いイメージを作るのです
カルマというのは 悪い
業（ごう）というのは 悪いことだと
業というのは 悪いことではないのです
我々の幸福も 過去の業なのです
我々の不幸も 過去の業なのです
業というのは
「過去の行いの結果」
という意味ですから
幸福・不幸 両方とも
過去の業なのです
「ある人はすごい幸福だ」
と言うならば
それは業なのです
「ある人は すごい不幸だな」
と言うならば
それはその人の業なのです
どっちでも
そこで皆様方に一つ
ご注意なのですけど
何でもかんでも簡単に
「業だ 業だ」と
決めつけることだけはやめてください
なぜかというと
業だけは 皆様方に理解できないのです
ときどき占いをやっている
色々予言したりする人々が
霊能力者ですか？
良く言うのです
「あなたの過去生でこういうことで
あなたは こうなっています」と
あれは ハッキリ言いますけど
嘘です
そんなに簡単 単純に
理解できるものではないのです
かなり難しいのです
そんなちょっとした
幽霊とか 何かお化けが
身体に付いたのだから
という感じで分かる訳ではないのです
ですから この業の問題は忘れてほしい
自分が病気なのは 過去の業だと
別にどうでも良いのです
それは忘れてほしいのです
とにかく
分かりませんから
とにかく それでも
業のせいで病気になったら
どうしますか？と
その場合は
良く分かることは
生まれつき病気になるか
或いは 突然病気になるか
それは 両方あります
なかなか 薬も効かない
治療法も効かない
何となく慢性的なようなものなのです
なかなか治らない
それに沿っていかなくては
いけないのです
と同時にその人の性格の中に
この原因は見えるのです
例えば がんになったと
がんになったのは
過去の業のせいだったら
当然 その人はすごいわがまま
高慢
自分勝手
結構 相手に迷惑をかける
そういう何かいやらしい性格があるのです
何か嫌な性格を持っているのです
それは 我々に分かるように
あぁ なるほど
こういう性格で 過去生で頑張って
そういうカルマになっているのだと
或いは すごい不親切とか
残酷な
優しいこころは持っていないとか
「商売の鬼」という風に
商売をやったら鬼みたいに
悪いことでもして商売をしたり とか
それで最後にどんどん
カルマの力が消えて行くと
悪いカルマが残ってしまって
もう病気になったりはするのです
だいたいその場合は もう
ほとんどどうしようもないのです
どうしようもないのは
カルマが分からないから
なのです
どんなカルマ どんな業を
やっていましたかと
分からないからなのです
その場合は 良くカルマのことを
勉強している
大変な仏教の知識がある
誰かに相談して
その場合だけ
誰かに良く相談して
自分の人生は良く見て
新しいカルマをする
新しい徳を積むようにする
そうすると
薬を飲むよりは
早く病気が治ります
具体的に今は言いません
カルマによって
やり方が違いますから
大体
良いのは
自分でもやっぱり
弱い人々を助けることなのです
いつでも
良くやってみて下さい
いつでも 弱い人を
優しいこころで助けてあげることを
いろんな弱さの人々がいるのです
それに動物も入るのです
動物も 全部生命
入っていて
ただ
必要な人が必要な時は
助けてあげて下さい
知識の助けが必要な人には
知識を与える
お金の助けが必要な人には
お金を与える
ちょっとした付き合いの
助けが必要な人には
付き合いをしてあげる
身体で手で助けてあげるべき人は
手助けをする
そういう風なことをしてあげてください
そうすると 自分の過去のカルマは
何であろうが
徐々に消えていきます
それから 助ける時は
ものすごく気をつけてください
助けられる側には
何の負担にもならないように
「ああ 申し訳ない」と
例えば 寝たきりの人がいて
私たちは看病をすると
そうすると寝たきりの人は
申し訳なく 申し訳なく
こころ苦しく思うならば
我々の助けは 助けになってないのです
ですから 私たちは
いつでも気を付けて
相手のこころを慰めてあげるのです
「やらせてください すみません」
「これは ぜひ私がやりたいのです」と
そんな感じで
こちらが「有難うございます」と
言わなくてはいけない
例えば 歩けない人は どこかへ
例えば 車いすの人は
階段があって 自分が運んであげたと
それで 向こうの人が
「ありがとう」と言う前に
「本当にどうもありがとうございます」と
自分には良いことは出来ましたから
向こう側に感謝するのです
そこはもうポイントです
それがないのだから
みんなもう良いことをします
でも それほど結果は味わえないのです
日本の方々は 結構
世界的に見ると
結構 立派な良いことをします
するのだけど
どうもちょっと 何かどこかで
その結果は得られないように感じます
なぜかというと
何か日本文化的に
向こう側から
一生懸命感謝して
褒めてほしがってしまうのです
その「褒めてもらいたい」という
これは皆様の苦しみの元なのです
いつでも感謝してほしいのです
だから 日本の文化というのは
無茶苦茶なのです
すごい ややこしいのです
まあ 中元やら
お正月になったら また色々
色々なものを贈ったり
またお返しに
ああだこうだとか
まあ それはそれなりに美しいのだけど
それはそれで置いておいて
でも
徳になるのは
それは徳にならない
徳になるのは 私は人を助けてあげてから
助けられた人に 私は
「ありがとうございます」と
という気持ちで 自分が感謝すること
それだけ良く覚えて
人々に優しくしてください
そうすると
カルマによって生まれる病気も治ります
またいろんなたくさんの方法が
あるのですが
どうしましょうか？
時間にはなりました
では この辺で
テーマのほんの一部なのです
今日しゃべったのは
まだたくさんあります
一応 あまり長くしゃべったとしても
全部 忘れてしまいますので
では ここら辺で
休憩します（了）